from the year 1914 to 1930 carl jung
embarked on a special spiritual journey
he called it the confrontation with the
unconscious and the result of this
confrontation was the legendary red book
the red book is essentially his personal
journal but crafted in a very artistic
and mystical way it includes parts of
his diaries called the black books as
well as illustrations calligraphy and
parts of religious texts like the bible
in latin language the creation of the
red book was a significant endeavor for
jung since it contains the nucleus of
his later works it was here that he
found inspiration for the conception of
his principal theories of the archetypes
the collective unconscious and the
process of individuation despite being
nominated as the central work in young's
uvra it was not published or made
otherwise accessible for study until
2009 in 2009 it was published complete
with an english translation three
appendices and over 1 500 editorial
notes the editor is professor sonu
samtasani who i believe did an excellent
job interpreting and editing this deep
and oftentimes peculiar work of art in
1958 jung said about his time working on
the red book the following the years
when i pursued the inner images were the
most important time of my life
everything else is to be derived from
this everything later was merely the
outer classification the scientific
elaboration and the integration into
life but the numinous beginning which
contained everything was then it is
quite interesting to explore the inner
workings of great minds and logical
questions arise for as to why jung
decided to embark on such a journey for
starters we need to understand that this
was the beginning of the 20th century it
was a very tumultuous time and the
groundwork for self-exploration was
quite fertile world war 1 had started
the church was considered of little
importance economic fatalism was
prevailing and the modern man was in
search of a soul psychology was at an
embryonic stage and the top thinkers of
the time had to experiment with
different practices in order to
understand the mechanics of our inner
world as sam dassani writes in the
beginning of the book psychologists
sought to overcome the limitations of
philosophical psychology
and they began to explore the same
terrain as artists and writers on all
sides individuals were searching for new
forms with which to depict the
actualities of inner experience in a
quest for spiritual and cultural renewal
it could also be that young realized at
some point that the material world isn't
all there is
daily life and everyday experience are
so tedious and superficial at times that
living becomes quite unbearable that is
probably the reason he decided to
approach life from a more experimental
way he surrendered to his dreams and
fantasies and the red book is the
manifestation of this surrender but
before we get into the gist of the book
let's try to answer an important
question what is the unconscious
jung has grappled with the unconscious
for a long time for him the unconscious
was a central mechanism in the
individuation process as it is stated in
wikipedia individuation is the process
of transformation whereby the personal
and collective unconscious are brought
into consciousness to be assimilated
into the whole personality so there are
two parts to the unconscious the
personal and the collective the personal
unconscious consists of memories and
emotions that the individual has
repressed
forgotten or rejected this shape our
behaviors and habits in ways that we are
not aware of they emerge to
consciousness mainly via the process of
psychotherapy and allow the individual
to realize ways in which their
unconscious is orchestrating their lives
the american psychological association
describes the collective unconscious as
follows the collective unconscious is
the part of the unconscious that
according to carl jung is common to all
humankind and contains the inherited
accumulation of primitive human
experiences in the form of ideas and
images called archetypes and manifested
in myths as well as other cultural
phenomena like religion and also in
dreams it is the deepest and least
accessible part of the unconscious mind
think of it this way every person
embodies patterns of behavior that are a
consequence of collective imitation
across time and generations and most of
these patterns have their roots in myths
religions and other cultural phenomena
in the nature of the psyche young writes
everything of which i know but of which
i'm not at the moment thinking
everything of which i was once conscious
but have now forgotten everything
perceived by my senses but not noted by
my conscious mind and everything which
involuntarily and without paying
attention to it i feel
think remember want and do
all the future things that are taking
shape in me and will some time come to
consciousness all this is the content of
the unconscious it makes sense that a
person that holds the idea of the
unconscious in such high esteem would
devote such a large part of his life in
investigating it and experimenting with
it the red book is a very intense read
the text is dense often poetic always
strange
it should be read slowly with an open
mind and with a willingness to immerse
oneself in the fantasies of another
person a deep analysis of the book
requires probably a whole movie for the
purposes of this video i will focus on
three parts that stood out for me and
can help one become enamored with the
bedrock of jungian thought
the first chapters of the book feel like
a node to the soul jung embarks on a
sequence of fantasy adventures in an
attempt to reconnect with a soul which
he feels he has abandoned due to the
materialistic
use and value nature of his time the
spirit of this time would like to hear
of use and value
i also thought this way and my humanity
still thinks this way but that other
spirit forces me nonetheless to speak
beyond justification use and meaning
filled with human pride and blinded by
the presumptuous spirit of the times i
long sought to hold that other spirit
away from me i think that this is
something all of us contemplate from
time to time the hectic and
result-oriented nature of our societies
render us oblivious to the demands of
our true self we focus too much on the
place of the fabricated world around us
and we eventually lose our soul until we
start crawling back to here my soul
where are you do you hear me i speak i
call you are you there i have returned
i'm here again i have taken the dust of
all the lands from my feet and i have
come to you i am with you after long
years of long wondering i have come to
you again should i tell you everything i
have seen experienced and drunken or do
you not want to hear about all the noise
of life and the world he whose desire
turns away from other things reaches the
place of the soul if he does not find
the soul the horror of emptiness will
overcome him and fear will drive him
with a whip lashing time and again in a
desperate endeavor and the blind desire
for the hollow things of the world my
friends it is wise to nourish the soul
otherwise you will breed dragons and
devils in your heart jung is quite
adamant with his approach for him the
lack of connection with the soul
engenders neurotic behaviors and
propagates problematic connections in
every stratum of the social edifice most
of the world's ugliness originates from
our separation with our psyche and as he
says when we don't nourish the soul we
breed dragons and devils in our hearts
sonu samdasani writes in the beginning
of the book the overall theme of the
book is how young regains his soul and
overcomes the contemporary malaise of
spiritual alienation this is ultimately
achieved through enabling the rebirth of
a new image of god in his soul and
developing a new worldview in the form
of a psychological and theological
cosmology the relationship between young
and god is a turbulent one he wrote a
lot about christianity and also eastern
religions he mainly tried to understand
and explain religion from a more
psychological standpoint throughout the
red book he encounters god and has
thoughts about his relationship with god
after a vision he has where he has to
kill a figure riding a chariot made from
the bones of the dead which is
presumably god a spirit of the depths
came to him and said the highest truth
is one and the same with the absurd then
he tries to analyze his thought and
writes in that night my life was
threatened since i had to kill my lord
and god not in single combat since who
among mortals could kill a god in a duel
you can reach your god only as an
assassin if you want to overcome him but
this is the bitterest for mortal men our
gods want to be overcome since they
require renewal if men kill their
princes they do so because they cannot
kill their gods and because they do not
know that they should kill their gods in
themselves if the god grows old he
becomes shadow nonsense and he goes down
the greatest truth becomes the greatest
lie the brightest day becomes the
darkest night
as day requires night night requires day
so meaning requires absurdity and
absurdity requires meaning there is too
much to unpack here but there are two
main ideas that stand out absurdity and
the death of god and jung tries to
create a bridge between the two
obviously the death of god refers to the
desperately needed renewal of
interpretation of religion but also in
the death of god inside us as he says
the god inside us must die so we can
experience a spiritual renewal and
awakening the god inside us must die
because we need to kill our obsession
with the ways of the superficial and
focus more on the ways of the psyche the
absurd is a liminal space between god
and us he alludes to that when he says
that the highest truth is one and the
same with the absurd it sounds
overwhelmingly unreasonable but for jung
truth is to be found beyond reason he
likes to play with duality and rethink
our approach towards the divine i
understood that the god whom we seek in
the absolute was not to be found in
absolute beauty goodness seriousness
elevation humanity or even in godliness
once the god was there i understood that
the new god would be in the relative if
the god is absolute beauty and goodness
how should he encompass the fullness of
life which is beautiful and hateful good
and evil laughable and serious human and
inhuman how can man live in the womb of
the god if the godhead himself attends
only to the one half of him
an interesting figure that appears in
jung's fantasies is philemon our first
encounter with him in the red book is as
follows after a long search i found a
small house in the country fronted by a
large bed of tulips this is where
philemon the magician lives with his
wife bosses vilemon is one of those
magicians who has not yet managed to ban
his old age but who lives it with
dignity and his wife can only do the
same their interests seem to have become
narrow even childish they water their
bed of tulips and tell each other about
the flowers that have newly appeared and
their days fade into a pale wavering
chiaroscuro which means light dark in
italian lit up by the past only slightly
frightened of the darkness of what is to
come then he approaches philemon and
starts a weird conversation with him
about black art people tell me that you
understand the black art
i'm interested in that will you tell me
about it what should i tell you about
there is nothing to tell don't be
ill-natured old man i want to learn
you're certainly more learned than i
what could i teach you the conversation
goes back and forth in a similar manner
jung asks philemon about magic and
philemon gives him vague answers magic
happens to be precisely everything that
eludes comprehension but then how the
devil is one to teach and learn magic
magic is neither to be taught nor
learned it's fool is that you want to
learn magic but then magic is nothing
but deception watch out you have started
reasoning again it's difficult to exist
without reason and that is exactly how
difficult magic is philemon is a figure
that also appears in the bible he is
closely related to paul the apostle and
his name means affectionate in greek not
sure why jung decided to associate
philemon with magic but it probably has
to do with his interest in magic at the
time he wrote this passage jung also
writes it is an error to believe that
there are magical practices that one can
learn one cannot understand magic one
can only understand what accords with
reason magic accords with unreason which
one cannot understand
the world accords not only with reason
but also with unreason probably when
jung speaks of magic he speaks of
everything that we don't understand he
alludes to the unconscious to chaos to
serendipity maybe to synchronicity
philemon is the person who possesses
magic hence he also possesses superior
insight he was youngsin zarathustra it
was quite important i guess for jung to
establish a fantastic connection with
such figures that stemmed from
mythopique imagination which was missing
in the present rational age shamdasani
writes the task of individuation lane
establishing a dialogue with the fantasy
figures or contents of the collective
unconscious and integrating them into
consciousness hence recovering the value
of the mythopique imagination which had
been lost to the modern age and thereby
reconciling the spirit of the time with
the spirit of the depth
as you can understand the red book is
open to multiple interpretations it can
be read as a novel it can be read as
mythology it can be read as the words of
a crazy man but that's its beauty and
appeal anyone can express themselves on
paper in an abstract and symbolic way
but jung owns this process to such a
degree that he has created the style
that can be called jungian just like
kafka's style is called kafkaesque again
let's not forget that jung is just a
curious man
trying to make sense of the world by
surrendering to his fantasies his
personal unconscious in tandem with the
collective unconscious are talking to
him and he is transforming their words
into images and narrative in his preface
to the 1952 revision of transformations
and symbols of the libido jung wrote
about the red book i was driven to ask
myself in all seriousness what is the
myth you are living
i found no answer to this question and
had to admit that i was not living with
a myth or even in a myth but rather in
an uncertain cloud of theoretical
possibilities which i was beginning to
regard with increasing distrust so in
the most natural way i took it upon
myself to get to know my myth and i
regarded this as the task of tasks for
so i told myself how could i when
treating my patients makes you allowance
for the personal factor for my personal
equation which is yet so necessary for a
knowledge of the other person if i was
unconscious of it and shamdasani adds
the study of myth had revealed to jung
his meetlessness he then undertook to
get to know his myth his personal
equation
by reading the red book we become fellow
travelers in a journey of
self-exploration that prompts us to ask
ourselves two quite thought-provoking
questions who am i really and what is my
myth hey guys hope you enjoyed today's
video if you did make sure to like
subscribe turn on notifications and
comment below something cool please so
that more people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrian out